I'm James lemon from analog shift today
we're gonna look at mechanical watches
and who's wearing them John Mayer John
is a avid wristwatch collector who has
all kinds of neat stuff
vintage contemporary has a focus on
vintage Rolex and modern Patek Phillipe
in this image we've got him wearing a 51
70 white gold chronograph this is really
the star mechanical chronograph of
pattex current line a chronograph is
basically a stopwatch for your wrist it
allows the keeping of time but it also
allows you to measure a secondary event
whether that's racing on the vehicle or
you know just how long it's taking at
the DMV and you find yourself timing
stuff all the time just by pressing a
button it's a very classical piece and
it has applied for gay indices which is
a font that's been used for hundreds of
years in pocket watches and wristwatches
alike the other image here is the 5160
for travel time Aquanaut which is the
big brother of this watch here it has a
second time zone but is ultimately the
same style of sporty steel Patek the
Aquanaut in question here might have a
retail price of under $50,000 but with
the Tiffany and company signature it's
probably worth close to three times that
on the secondary market so a double sign
watch means that it has the name of the
manufacturer on the dial but it also has
the name of a retailer in this case
Tiffany and company is the legendary
jeweler and when you have a Tiffany and
company signature on your Patek Phillipe
it adds extra exclusivity and value but
actually doesn't increase the price at
retail the secondary market on the other
hand is an entirely different story
so John Mayer is a real horological
enthusiast to collecting a wide variety
of things as well as this absolutely
bonkers concept corner chronograph with
the white strap which is part of their
sort of forward-looking almost
experimental line when you have an
openwork dial it's another word would be
skeletonized you can see the inner
workings
the movement here it's fitted in a
titanium case that's massively oversized
and fitted on a sports strap ed sheeran
is an absolute horological
fanatic like John Mayer his case are
varied he's got vintage and contemporary
but he's probably best known for his
love of patek philippe here we have ed
wearing the reference $24.99 which is
considered by many of the most elite
wristwatch collectors to be one of the
finest chronograph perpetual calendars
ever made this is a vintage watch and he
went to great lengths to get this it's a
wonderful wonderful piece of history and
design essentially a perpetual calendar
will tell you all of the things you need
to know about what day week month phase
of the Moon is going on right now
without ever having to change or set it
it is one of the most sought after and
[ __ ] logically significant
complications in the entire lineup with
only one thing surpassing it and Edie
has one of those too here it is wearing
the mother of all watches this is the
Patek Phillipe reference 5208
p grande complication so what we have
here is a perpetual calendar and the
addition of a mono pusher chronograph
which is activated start and stop and
reset from a single button instead of
two like you'd find on the normal
stopwatch chronograph and last but not
least it has a minute repeater when
activated it will chime the hours and
minutes of the time just like an old
grandfather clock this is unbelievable
absolutely insane and the best of the
best
JZ is a legendary rapper sure you've all
heard of him and also his taste for
watches is also legendary here we've got
him wearing a Rolex day-date with a
black dial and a smooth bezel the rolex
day-date is really the flagship of
Rolexes dress and luxury collection
unlike a date just which has just a date
the day date has the date and the day
the word iconic is thrown around
probably too much in the wristwatch
industry but the rolex day-date is
without question one of the most
identifiable and iconic watches of all
time it is a sign of success is a sign
of taste and it has a nickname president
for a reason and of course Jay also has
a rashard mil this is an RM 56 which has
been customized totally with a blue
sapphire case Bob which reportedly took
3000 hours to make and cost about two
and a half million dollars I guess if
you've got it and you want to customize
something that's already incredibly rare
this is how you do it Jay also has an
appreciation for the classics this is
probably the most interesting watch in
Jay Z's collection this is a Rolex date
just from the 1980s in solid gold and
frankly by itself that doesn't lend
itself to being anything terribly
special but this particular watch is a
piece unique it was modified by
legendary designer Franck Muller who was
also the namesake of his own brand in
the 1980s he took this date just he
ripped out its guts and he built a
totally custom perpetual calendar made
his own dial for this watch and put it
all together I'm not quite sure how it
ended up in Jays hands or on his wrist
so to speak but my god that is a very
very special watch and it shows just
what you can do with a little bit of
mechanical engineering and design
spectacular
Jeff is wearing the 2018 cardi a Santos
this is the full-size model an 18 karat
solid gold this is a magnificent
reinterpretation of one of the most
historically significant cardioid
designs this is a small thin precious
metal dress wash but would you believe
it started out as the first pilots watch
this watch features a brilliantly
designed integrated bracelet that is
removable without the use of tools using
your fingers you can pull the bracelet
off by unlocking integrated clasps it is
ultra thin automatic instant absolutely
stunning here Jake is wearing the steel
mid sized version I actually prefer the
mid-sized I bought a midsize when I
bought mine here it's just completely
steel it's a great value as well as I
think about $7,000
it offers I think a lot of horological
and design chops in a versatile package
that could be used for dress or for
daily wear alike fantastic watch Brian
Gosling is a man after my own heart and
not just because he's so handsome here
we have ryan wearing a vintage Rolex
heir case the air King is really
absolute lowest slot and Rolex is sort
of collection if you're looking for
something that has character and style
and patina and oozes this romantic ideal
of what this watch has been through this
is it this particular watch probably
dates to the 1950s or 60s it is 34
millimeter size which is a little small
by today's standards but wears
brilliantly on a variety of wrist sizes
depending on how you strap it up on a
bracelet or a leather strap ultimately
this is sort of all you need and I think
Ryan is sort of
proving minimalism is also very
effective here offset is wearing a RM 11
coronagraph from rashard mill sort of a
classic entry-level chronograph in the
restart mill collection this is a RM
1101 as well this one is a roberto
mancini edition but it also has been
edged out with aftermarket gem setting
in short taking a factory watch and then
taking it to a jeweler on our craftsman
who is applying additional gem setting
and doing additional precious stones
onto the watch totally sets him apart
here we have offset wearing a very
interesting launch while at first glance
this Royal Oak appears to be gem says
it's not it's what aap calls frosted
gold it's actually a factory case
finishing in which an individual hand
finishes a Florentine pattern into a
white gold case basically making it
Sparkle these things are amazing to
behold and while it isn't a precious
stone it is a precious metal and there's
a beautiful shimmery almost snow like
effect to these watches this is a really
neat watch it's almost a peas way of
responding to everyone who went and got
aftermarket diamonds fitted they said
well you don't need diamonds we can make
this thing Sparkle just using the gold
magnificent and here offset is wearing a
Rolex date just pearl master and believe
it or not this thing is completely
factory there
no appearances to me of any type of
aftermarket fitting it has an unusual
bracelet that differs from the standard
oyster bracelet it has a sunburst style
and it has this really cool gem set
bezel this is pretty neat watch and not
something you see every day really
doesn't need anything it's perfect the
way I left the factory
[Music]
huevo is wearing a Royal Oak chronograph
this is usually a 39 to 41 millimeter
size looks to be rose gold completely
fitted with diamond setting iced out to
the max looks really good the
workmanship on on this particular iced
out a pea it impresses me immediately
just for the subtlety and its and the
way that the stones are set into the
case they look perfectly set oftentimes
with shoddy work you see some extra slag
and gold material coming off the sides
but all of these seem to be fit really
really expertly adding expensive things
does not necessarily mean your watches
worth more if it's done poorly or you
use shoddy workmanship you can take a
watch that had inherent value and
destroy it by having it modified my
advice to anybody who's looking at
modifying her wristwatches to go ahead
and do it just make sure it's done well
and make sure that it is for you take
off style is a little different than the
other band members and migos and a
little bit more restrained I'd say he's
wearing a Rolex shalini this is a Rolex
that even Rolex people don't usually
know anything about this particular
model appears to be rose gold and also
has a moon fades indicator this is
really interesting sort of non rolex
rolex it's very much a Rolex
but it's not what you would picture if I
said the word
robots for that reason I think that
shalini line which is diverse and has
all kinds of different materials and
shapes and complications is sort of one
of the under some beauties of the modern
watch collecting light-up rami malek
Romney is a big fan of Cartier and what
we have him wearing here is the cardiac
tank American this is a slightly
different style than the classic tank
Louis Cartier which was actually
fashioned to look like the profile of a
World War 1 French battle tank the tank
American is also a tank design that it
has elongated sides that taper into
these lugs at the end where you fit the
strap on but the actual central carriage
is slightly more rectangular and the
whole case is slightly curved making it
a truly black-tie worthy dress watch it
has very classical design elements for
the Cartier brand including the blue
sapphire cabochon crown as blued steel
hands these are hands that are actually
glued over an open flame by an art by an
artist one at a time and if you overcook
it so to speak you lose the color and
you have to start again so there's a
real handcrafted nature to what has
ultimately become one of the most
prevalent dress watch models kanye west
is wearing a Cartier crash this is a
very interesting launch as legend goes
drew its inspiration from a cardio wrist
launch that was burned in a car crash
and was returned to Cartier for repair
where the designers took a look at it
and saw this art form in its mangled
shape the cartier crash has been made a
few times this is a very particularly
early one with a London signed dial and
has gradually been made occasionally in
production always selling out always
being in demand the cardiac crash is
simply one of those
that looks unlike anything else and also
proves that the French have a sense of
humor great watches can be had at any
price point we're talking a lot about
some very high-end and customized stuff
today but if you have an interest in
mechanical watches there are great
options at virtually every price for it
starting with a few hundred dollars and
up the best piece of advice I can give
to anybody who's interested in getting
into mechanical wristwatches is to learn
as much as you can find somebody to help
you read about them
I've also wear them and see how they
make you feel these are things that we
don't need but there are things that
have authenticity and have story and can
really make you feel a certain way so
try them on learn about them and have
fun with it